hey guys Greg here I'm John so many
people have been requesting that we
check out marvels cloaks and dagger the
cloak and dagger trailer little Pines
Channel with the first request I found
when I scroll through all the comments
but hey we recently watched the patreon
we did you guys have been [ __ ]
incredible without everything I'm yeah
are you happy 4/20 by the way happy 4/20
but so and donated like way more than we
ever thought anyone would donate it was
it was crazy it tripped us out and I
sent it like message Garrett's hood
Garrett my locker go to get $250 yeah
highest jewelry at we have currently at
$60 over said bullion and my friend I
asked him for his address like where can
we mail some stuff to you and he's like
I live in a far far far island or
something funny and he said the next
time is out in California you know like
we can meet up guess what buddy knew
what I was gonna meet up you're gonna
come on this chanting to come on the
chin like come on the channel you're
going to crash here than I weigh to come
on the channel everywhere all over the
camera and it's going to be a very
upsetting experience for everyone yeah
restricted video yeah and lose some nuts
man so anyway get to the reaction
already yeah we're already we'll start
putting these more towards the end okay
[Music]
[ __ ] whoa
[Music]
that night my rat anything
what just happened it's like you're
afraid if I don't do anything perfectly
you're gonna lose it I'm afraid
even if you do everything perfectly
under Oh
whoa what's your name Teddy yeah Tyrone
I want the origin story how it started
the channel oh [ __ ] oh shoot
[Music]
oh [ __ ] cloak-and-dagger daggers this is
like an origin story in a trick clothes
that looks cool that looks really cool
Alex really really kid you not two days
ago I started showing John daredevil
he's on Episode three I don't know what
this is going on clothes freeform I
don't know dude black didn't a chick
that they hate white people man I'm just
gonna say interracial love up in the
hood yeah no this looks like you love it
I'm really excited like I like what
Marvel TV is doing perhaps multi-item at
least the continuous like superhero
Cinematic Universe and Tipper what I've
heard about him you know like yeah
everything has been kind of distinct and
impressive to me about the TV and this
looks way cooler oh dude this just
reminded me of the trailer for slight
yeah a little bit like that I was really
surprised by it because you know from
the little information I got I'm like
okay I got a general idea for who they
are these teenagers they come into each
other's lives something happens with
drugs their story from what I understand
is like it focuses on when they get
their powers they they kind of go after
like people who deal with drugs okay Oh
interesting I could be so wrong nobody
you know that I only superheroes like
that's actually that's what I was
appreciating my watching both Daredevil
and Jessica Jones is like oh yeah these
are the people who help the regular
people now yeah like you know during the
no dia the movies are for the big
disaster it's a no yes or the planet
that's what they're reserved for you
know yeah and these guys are more for
the people in the streets so the real
hero yeah he'll and like Marvel
pretty consistent about casting good
actors and like I really admire that
they seem to have taken initiative sort
of a responsibility within a superhero
genre to keep broadening out what it
looks like and how it feels absolutely
and yeah this is like a teen drama when
I was watching us how myself getting
pulled into it their chemistry seems a
tad bit off to me if I'm going to be
completely honest though but see whether
interacting was cute there's a certain
caliber of acting excluding Finn Jones
Danny ran that I expect from these
Marvel shows that it was so brief we
didn't see anything leading up to that
you know but it seemed a little bit like
they were acting okay I didn't really
feel that they were being completely
real but it is it's based on the pilot
yeah probably yeah before everybody knew
how much how deep to get it is it any
more like a trailer for the first
episode this left me wondering is the
season going to tell me there are their
origin together or this from like early
on but it felt pretty much like an
origin because I got yeah felt like the
first episode in me in a lot of ways I
felt like it would end when they have we
did they discover each other's Towers
when they run into it or something
happened yeah it has a second episode or
something beyond that like one scene
where I had a tiny nitpick about I think
the rest of the trailer they were doing
a great job when all their other scenes
yeah and it's a different mood in a
different setting like a little
pentameter bat teeny these like
everything like seventeen or something
but even even just where they are like
like yeah this like Detroiters is like
small Midwestern town somewhere or even
you know like just in the middle yeah
I'm glad that we're flipping up the
scenery too you know because this looks
like it had it looks like the setting is
going to be a character in this also you
know one thing I think is really about
the marketing behind this if I may input
something that I think is smart of me to
say right now is oh [ __ ] I got I thought
it was so funny I forgot what I was
saying god dude do it live wait write it
down we'll stop talking you're ruining
thoughts okay no one really knows who
cloak and dagger is I'd be very
surprised if I'm like talking to a group
of people and I'm like the only one who
doesn't know
cloak-and-dagger so infinitive clever is
it didn't capitalize on their powers and
abilities they capitalized on their
backstories and who they are and when
they need
I found myself invested in who they are
as people and then when the power
started coming in it was sort of like oh
yeah there's that [ __ ] yeah for a good
amount of this trailer I didn't know if
super powers and I was like is this one
of their like other books and like like
more really granted yeah you know it is
a human being if you have like real life
problems to deal with yeah this is like
what life becomes recycling but yeah I
don't know that much about those words
that my name up might not be a good
careful John comic book people are
watching they will destroy us for not
knowing a single thing like I'm gonna do
something this looks like even deeper
just into the the life in movie a died
of Marvel dude it feels like Kathryn
Bigelow Direction naturalistic I'm
excited man I'm looking forward to this
oh yeah what the hell is freeform I've
heard the name flow to a channel that
actually exists yeah I think so what
they're owned by Disney of course they
are
Disney did ABC Family become this is
that what happened I don't know
networks slogan I don't care anymore
I'll find out how to watch this thing
I'll probably buy episodes of Amazon hey
guy thanks for tuning in
subscription services are free on the
real rejects go subscribe it's free yeah
won't hurt anybody John yeah his reasons
that Jerry on Twitter and Instagram he's
a social media manager of Blum house and
the real rejects shout out again to
Gareth Evans for donating to us